it's the man the myth the comedy icon
the one and only bob newhart the e.t
exclusive
first of all how are you feeling i feel
great i just turned 92. it's been a
great life it's just you know making
people laugh is
it's wonderful i love you america
and america loves you right back bob i
mean what an honor it was spending the
day with this legend at his los angeles
home he's celebrating 62 years in show
business
hello
for me bob newhart's show was like it
was appointment viewing well we were at
cbs saturday night lineup all in the
family
nash
mary tyler moore us and carol burnett
and we used to get like
super bowl numbers
bob shot his show on the cbs radford lot
which is also where we shoot e.t
that has such great memories i spent 14
years there and mary tyler moore was at
seinfeld with her what was the magic of
having all those people there at the
same time you know you get passed by ted
and ed
you know from ed asner yeah and ted
knight
but bob had a little known secret
i had the lines on the back of a cereal
box
and the cereal box was there but it was
turned the wrong way
because my lines were on the other side
the director he said cut cut cut cut
said bob
nobody turns the cereal box around i
said okay you're right you're right but
that's where the words work there are
some real time i mean i see you see
richard pryor ed sullivan ted sullivan
johnny carson team martin
bob's home is filled with memories with
his fellow comedians awards magazine
covers even all the scripts from the bob
newhart show and newhart one of his most
treasured pieces of memorabilia is this
letter from jfk signed just five months
before his assassination it was the
president's birthday and i entertained
at it and
received a letter from
president kennedy
that said enjoyed it greatly that's
amazing i want to play an interview we
did with you in 1986. man i belong on
television i don't really belong in
movies i tried movies and they didn't
work movies did work for you
well elf elf work i'll always be here
for you what was it like making elf
it was a joy that movie almost couldn't
have made it because if will came off as
just a jerk doesn't he realize he's he's
not an elf but he was able you just
cared for him so much yeah that you
wanted it to be true
all right let's talk about big bang
theory is he dangerous
how much fun was that it was great i
like
big bang i like the writing on it i
think the cast is incredible any chance
that you could pop up on young sheldon i
hate to say no
you never say no
although bob has won an emmy for acting
his first love was stand-up comedy in
fact his first two comedy albums in the
early 1960s outsold all other records
and won him three grammys so you win
album of the year in 1960 and you beat
out
some pretty um impressive people
um
frank sinatra
i don't think i don't think frank was
too thrilled about moving to a
to a comic
now bob is showcasing some of his
classic comedy routines in the vinyl
re-release of his 1992 tv special off
the record which is on sale now how fast
were you going when when mr adams jumped
from the car
i said i'd like to do
some of the early routines i'd like to
do them again
but the most important thing in bob's
life his wife jenny their four kids and
10 grandkids in a crazy business in a
crazy town you've been married for 58
years
how have you pulled that off comedians
marriages
tend to laugh
there's something about laughter
and the length of a marriage
jack benny george burns don rickles for
some reason
laughter and marriage
work
they last
she knows me better than you know the
comedian and his ego get in the way but
but she she cuts right to to the bone
and
she's been writing time and time again
oh she god if she sees this
[Music]